[Music]
in time news man submitted by hi JK from
Angela Hawaiian hello Los Angeles and
hello hey that's nice a man killed his
family after sending $200,000 to a
European cam girl holy SH went doll
hairs dollars dollars a man kills his
family after $200,000 Dan that's a bald
ass dog so he he he jacks off to a cam
girl and then he comes it all away and
then he kills his own family for that no
let me tell you okay tell me to do
kazanka his wife found out
no so he's in death he killed his family
just poking her hi dad it's a broken yes
so this guy his name is grant he's 29
years old
200 he must be amazing she better be so
he allegedly stole this money from his
own family and sent it to a cam girl in
Bulgaria that's just probably [ __ ]
lethal the [ __ ] I mean well he's from
Florida
oh man and Florida man watching the
[ __ ]
o Lord of the bird crazy there's
something of water out there dude she
probably does squirt shows or something
amazing so that's why he work yeah it's
like when they get naked internet soda
no oh that sounds hot it's when the
vagina shoots out liquid like the [ __ ]
hole yeah do that is that pee I don't
know oh it's mid there's there might be
some pee in there it's a little bit I
don't look that up that's what that's
what the [ __ ] asking it I know about the
no but then the show though I don't know
if it naturally happens I feel like they
[ __ ] pre like pump that [ __ ] with
with
[ __ ] smash it down it happens happen
well I know it happens before the shows
though probably amount that comes out so
crazier it's like you can fill a water
bottle Philip that [ __ ] is that pee pee
maybe they're higher than presents David
it happens like water bowl fill yeah it
happened I know it happens in nature
that's because that had happen at one
time okay and I thought the bed was
disgusting alright so wait let me tell
you about the story here so grant he
killed his father who's 59 was 59 his
mother who was 61 he and his brother
Cody who was 31 why oh I thought his
like memory I was married and got his
wife because he should know but it's
just
while he's a loser even more of a loser
Wow yeah he was kicked out of nursing
and I said endless anaesthesia
anesthesia an estate this one and I
missus anaesthetise that one yeah school
and oh he was in that school yes it's
not to be a CRNA exactly see babe get
paid really hard the whole time he's
working on it he's just thinking about
the cam show those holes are pollen yeah
that's why he needed to supply them oh
and work so hard so you can get more cam
gross time that's the highest paid under
what yeah that's what he was 170
although ours are awful though I bet no
170 that's pretty good
seniority we got the good [ __ ] anyway so
um so he got kicked out of that school
because he was arrested because they
found out that he was taking this power
too powerful sedative from the hospital
and he was telling investigators that he
had been he hadn't been using or selling
the drug but that he was administering
it on patients who believed needed more
comfort so so then that whole thing this
arrest warrant at the day
that they were looking into he also
mentioned that he expressed suicidal
thoughts but there were no charges filed
on that case
but then move forward he moved back in
with his parents and Ann in June he
started a relationship with a woman in
Bulgaria through a porn web cam sites
relations not a relationship
relationship the strippers love me I
know she loves me concerned she became
concerned because the woman started
sending mail to the family home after he
gave her their address oh [ __ ]
and this is all according to a third son
named Jason who was not there at the
time of the murders so oh my god he's
the only survivor oh really well and
then the guy that killed his family yeah
his brother yeah so then um Jason said
that his brother has stolen one hundred
and fifty thousand dollars from the
father and that also included taking out
a sixty five thousand dollar loan on the
parents home in order to fund his
addiction and then he was also suspected
of taking fifty thousand dollars to
sixty five thousand dollars from his
brother Cody as well as Cody's guns
which Cody's the other brother that he
did kill and then he sold these guns
without Cody's permission mhm and then
he sent all this money to this cam girl
within a three-month period Jesus so
then the family found out and then they
put him in a rehab facility to treat his
pornography addiction and he stayed
there for two weeks but then he left the
facility he'd returned back you need to
get back to that Bulgarian [ __ ] that's
why yeah so then that's when the family
presented him with the two-page list of
things like like rules that he needs to
follow in order to remain at the home
and then he said his dad said that he
would have to stop talking to that girl
and so initially he did agree to the
rules he stopped talking to the girl
after stealing 200k do I wait that's
what he did after 200k yeah you got
those rules how do you even have access
to their bank accounts I don't know
and I will [ __ ] strip that boy naked
in the whole entire room and he will
work for that 200k so what ended up
happening is that the dad found out that
he was secretly still talking to this
girl through Twitter and so then that's
when the dad just said like that was it
he had enough he kicked him out of the
home and that's when he killed him how
did he do it with that damn so then he
got the parents called Cody over cuz he
doesn't live with them so then Cody's
girlfriend told the authorities that he
left and he was he was like wait Cody's
a killer Cody's the brother that died um
so then like Cody told the girlfriend
like like you know why are you leaving
and she was like oh stupid [ __ ]
[ __ ] then he ended up going she sent
him a text thirty minutes later to ask
if he was okay he replied all okay and
that she didn't need to worry about him
and then that was the last time she ever
heard from him
because then they found out that grant
killed Cody big dudes [ __ ] up it says
here that the officers they used the
knife to open the dead bolt on the back
door and then they immediately
discovered the dads body lying in the
kitchen in a pool of dried blood the
mom's body was slumped in a chair and at
an office desk and in Cody's body was
cradled in a fetal position in the
garage storage room with blood coming
out of his eyes because everyone was
shot in the head execution-style oh wow
don't get in between a loser and his cam
girl because that's his lifeline I bet
you that's his life and then the Cody's
girlfriend was saying that Cody once
said like you know I'm scared he's gonna
kill us this kid had issues dude yeah
imagine him actually becoming a nurse
that would have been really bad you know
so what do you think he did with that
anesthetic he was probably using it like
on himself or like to rape people oh I
don't know they haven't said anything
about rape because this is a case of
parents not doing a damn thing I mean
after I mean like think about how nice
these parents are right two hundred
thousand dollars [ __ ] stole your
brother's guns all this [ __ ] and
then you go alright
here's a [ __ ] list of rules
we're not doing this anymore to [ __ ]
light man by that point you're either
burying him in the backyard up to his
neck and then every day he just has to
be like a [ __ ] bird's nest
for like a month or you imagine going
toe-to-toe you're in your late fifties
early sixties now twenty nine-year-old
yeah your kids almost 30 you know what
though I'm always gonna be crazier but
you're gonna be slowly crazy
you might they might be fit but I'll
always be psychologically [ __ ]
puppeteering what but you're gonna
forget where you leave your keys every
five minutes I'm still 50 I'll be sharp
it'll probably water Mortimer's if you
[ __ ] with me and think about it he's
gonna age with me right if I'm 80 that
[ __ ] 60 or 50 or whatever - now
what's up we're still the same now
what's this prime I've seen what I've
seen also - because your kid's gonna
grow up in a nice niceness yeah he's a
little [ __ ] dude that's what I'm saying
[ __ ] drop all [ __ ] gutter homes
you're gonna see what I see that's why
you shelter your kids so that if you
shelter your kids they're always weaker
than you looks like he like scam girls
are just shape the whole thing everyone
looks like an egg you know you know what
you know what's interesting this is the
family oh look at that handsome father
got the looks and go go back to the bald
[ __ ] don't say that he was can you go
back to the bald [ __ ] so I've been
watching these videos right what people
do hair transplants right and they will
advise anyone it's not that I'm talking
about they put a wig like a glued wig on
and they cut in style I bet you they put
one on this [ __ ] he's gonna look
good that won't look like Captain Kirk I
don't think uh yeah look you got a
bad-looking dude is creepy a little bit
more way yeah but look at his face he's
actually not a bad lookin dude who he
looks like a Klingon
look just like that and they put hair on
them yeah [ __ ] handsome yeah big
difference yeah captain I think this
fool is just like nutty he's not there
another photo of him when he's writing
on the camera cute they see when you
come up ahead he's like Count Dracula
I know wonder where that camera went to
now pay the money back her fault she
know what she had I'm sure like what if
she told him to kill you you don't know
that yeah but if she's one of those
girls doing her job and this guy went
crazy you can't really I don't respect I
think I would give the money back
I had a respect if I was at cam girl I
would have given at least 25% back yeah
I live in funky I live in Bulgaria I
mean dude she's like probably like
bringing in 50% of the GDP of Bourget
Bulgaria so you can't I recently became
obsessed with this this girl who streams
on Twitch she's from Georgia the
Republic the country of Georgia
kocchi dude yeah it's called Georgia and
she is fine like she looks like one of
those Russian Instagram girls but she
discusses politics because she graduated
whatever whatever and she is so fine and
so smart
hmm so smart and so sad so show some
master's in something whatever we should
I don't follow
she uh I don't like smart people because
they're just talking all the time and
they don't actually do nothing but she
she made like four thousand dollars in
one day okay I like her now she's cool
never seen a thousand dollar Sun Harris
but he's like a circle it's like a link
because I'm like how can you be
beautiful okay intellectual and
[ __ ] business that's not fair
you got weird feet feet photos they
always offer I'm like they always want
me send them feet give them your feet
but they never pay me I want them to pay
me for my feet phony do you send them
the photos no tell them I knew I needed
75% of the money up front I'll send you
the [ __ ] feet then you give me the
25% at the tail end the reason I don't
respond to them either but nobody ever
offers
hey so just write off about y'all so
send you money for feet and so just they
send the money first I'll be like cool
I'll send you a picture of my feet if
you give me [ __ ] four grand right now
Express cold hard digital cash they
won't take the photos for you David do a
whole photo shoot
I'll do all up with flowers next to Anna
[ __ ] dude yeah oh poor [ __ ] no what's
it called the [ __ ] oil drops milk on
it shows I'll give you my feet for free
[Laughter]
blood blister there's always feel really
feminine feminine I [ __ ] can rock
it's a really good art how are you I
need it in between nine and a half or
ten I know I could rock some [ __ ]
heels Oh [ __ ] field yeah like you
have like Asian come find feet through
this no no this is Asian [ __ ] you buy
the paper yeah
[Music]